[Musique]
la bouille le film de claude pinoteau
est sorti au cinéma le 17 décembre 1980
il a révélé sophie marceau elle incarne
vic une adolescente qui ne pense qu'à
une chose participer à sa première boum
est celle d'une jeune fille qui qui a 13
ans et à ton amoureuse d'un garçon
on pourrait penser que les années 80
était l'âge d'or des boums il n'en est
rien dès les années 50 une initiative
des étudiants de hec et médiatisé on
parle alors de boon au masculin
ça s'appelle le boom hec et la recette
est déjà là des garçons des filles de la
musique de la danse mais avec orchestre
et robes de soirée
ce modèle un poil guindé explose dans
les années 60 avec l'arrivée des yéyés
du rock et du tourne-disque à l'époque
la majorité est à 21 ans donc impossible
pour les jeunes de sortir en boîte pour
s'amuser et se libérer du carcan de la
société ils organisent eux-mêmes des
surprises parties dans les salons les
garages et les câbles et c'est là qu'ils
se réunissent le samedi lé dinh ans pour
danser car promis d'organiser eux-mêmes
leurs loisirs les organise selon leur
désir n'est pas question bien entendu de
loisirs intellectuelle alors ils sont là
une bouffée d'oxygène qui ne rateraient
pour rien au monde
vous venez souvent surprise party comme
ça qu'on tienne là même tous les combien
ce n'est pas une surprise partie les
jeunes ne s'interdisent rien cigarettes
alcool aidant que si vous danser le
twist madison à tous pas vraiment ce
gars on oublie le slow en 1963 l'école
n'est toujours pas mixtes pas facile
alors pour ces ados de flirter labine
devient le lieu où l'on découvre l'autre
sexe et le slot
l' arme fatale des séducteurs en herbe
en 1981 à la sortie du film les loups
pour changer les adolescents danse sur
d'autres musiques
mais une chose subsistent est-ce qu'on
drague alors on drague beaucoup j'essaye
[Musique]